8 million on the hoverbikes 20 million on the
laser cannon 30 million for the airships and
49.95 for the software that lets me
put price tags on video footage that
that last thing let's cut that am i good
businessman we need to talk about the leadership
of this organization how dare you questioned my
what what the hell is that an experiment now it's
time you see jesus it just pissed out of what i
thought was its mouth it's fine but aim is not
because you have to feel okay it just scratched
kill me into the linoleum i said it's fine
it's time you step down and let me run aim uh yeah
about that uh if these numbers are correct soon
there won't be any aim to run at all what we're
completely out of cash even accounting for sales
of weapons stolen vibranium and bootleg avengers
toys some kids prefer spooderman even so we're
bankrupt impossible you are hereby relieved of
your status as cpa supreme and as a living person
remember i still need to do your personal taxes so
i'm sorry i i thought this coffee was for everyone
all right we need big ideas to save aim
you guys are my brain trust what have you
got for me blood car what's that it's car
that runs on blood terrible what else oh
we watch wolf of wall street and do what the wolf
does he said stop pitching that what else your uh
toilet's broken i like it i don't understand it
but i like it i still don't have a bar mitzvah
suit i'm looking for the right fabric do you mind
if i have a feel real quick not at all son of
motor stop fondling my brain truck dad one of your
dumb asses spilled acid all over my boyfriend come
on guys acid is expensive monok can i talk to you
for a minute i was listening at the door and just
my two cents but maybe it's time to let aim go
never modok doesn't give up flailerg isn't even
in my vocabulary were you trying to say failure
yes i literally deleted it from my memory banks
you don't have to worry i'm making enough
to support us maybe it's my turn to take the
reins aim is modok modok is aim without it i i
wouldn't even know who i am wow if that's true
i think we need to have a very serious
conversation about what that means for us
oh i'll get it i hope it's the cool mailman
welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new avengers modok trailer for the new
marvel series that they're doing early next year
so i'll explain what's going on with this where it
fits in the timeline and what they're doing with
the character big marvel phase 4 movie easter
eggs with modok so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything we'll do a new
amazon giveaway all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and since they're doing a very robot
chicken-like take on the series let me know which
other characters you want them to bring on the
show and make fun of so we'll number these as we
go along just to stay organized but if you have no
idea what's going on with this or you didn't
know that they were doing a modok tv series
it's a very robot chicken looking marvel series
about the modok character as he tries to run aim
from one of the guys from family guy american dad
seth macfarlane's team he also worked on community
at the same time the russo brothers were working
on communities so a bit of a marvel connection
going way back with patton oswalt playing
the modok character and some of the other
actors you'll probably recognize like they have
ben schwartz who was just the voice of sonic he
also did a bunch of robot chicken episodes back
in the day you probably recognize the voice of
the daughter that modok has played by the person
from brooklyn nine-nine here and the person from
lucifer so there's a lot of very meta stuff going
on with this in the marvel cinematic universe
and the reason why it looks like robot chicken
is because it's made by the robot chicken team at
stupid buddies studios so tonally it's also very
similar to robot chicken and the way it parodies
marvel avengers characters it's just that because
this is a marvel series unlike robot chicken most
of their jokes will probably just be about marvel
stuff so not so much dc stuff but to be fair they
do actually reference marvel avengers characters
all the time on the live action flash tv show so
technically there's no actual rule about what they
can make fun of i think they're just not allowed
to have dc characters show up on screen but the
basic plot of the series when episode one picks
up is that modok has run aim into the ground with
all his failed schemes to destroy the avengers
and take over the world so with the company in
ruins an evil version of google swoops in to try
and buy the company and revitalize it the way a
normal business would reorganize itself to become
profitable again they basically tell modok that
you can still orchestrate all your evil schemes
to destroy the avengers take over the world but
they tell him he has to make aim profitable by the
end of the year or that's it and it goes in a very
arrested development direction with him being kind
of like the michael character at the center of it
all trying to run aim the way he wants to be this
supreme being but having to put up with all these
people around him being like the bluth family
either incompetent idiots or they forced him to
attend too many meetings so he slowly starts to
spiral out of control as he loses control of the
company and the character himself is all about
control as you also saw during the trailer they
gave him a family that you've never met before
in the comics that he goes home to every night
apparently in new jersey that's where modok lives
within the context of this series that feels like
a very robot chicken thing to do like modok has a
life of his own outside of aim and he lives in new
jersey with his wife and children like one of the
children here looks like a giant floating head
just like modok but the other kid played by ben
schwartz looks normal the really cool thing that
pat and oswalt and the showrunner said is that
they were allowed to use big x-men characters they
were really surprised by they were like marvel's
really going to let us do this we pulled from
everywhere uh so like patton said yes there's some
x stuff hopefully we're allowed to say that yeah
let's just leave it at that you notice behind the
showrunner there he has a bunch of x-men comics
and even held up a bunch of classic trading cards
from x-men the animated series which makes me
wonder if a lot of the parody and easter eggs
and references they make during the series are
for x-men the animated series i think it's a
little bit easier for them to use x-men characters
like that before the live-action mcu movies and
tv shows do just because it is animation there's
more suspension of disbelief so it's a little bit
easier to get away with stuff like that they said
that what they did is they treated the mcu cannon
the same way spider-man into the spider-verse
treated the spider-man cannon they pull from
everything that's come before all the tv
shows every comic book every big mcu movie
everything together at the same time canonizing it
through the show the same way that spider-man into
the spider-verse did miles morales but it also
did toby mcguire live-action spider-man movie
easter eggs spider-pig black and white spider-man
noir spider-gwen penny parker from the future
and spider-man 2099 just to name a few things so
imagine the robot chicken people doing something
more like spider-man into the spider-verse but
just traditionally with marvel avengers characters
originally the marvel people behind this and a
bunch of other animated shows they were developing
for hulu were going to do a new version of the
netflix defender style team up with animated shows
they were going to do the modok show they
were going to do a hit monkey show tigra and
dazzler series in the howard the duck animated
series that kevin smith was working on all those
characters were eventually going to cross over in
a netflix defender style crossover series called
the offenders so obviously they're trading
very heavily on defenders netflix references
but then what happened is they reorganized marvel
tv under marvel studios kevin feige took over the
development of all the tv series and some of
them got cancelled so they wound up canceling
the tigra and dazzler series i also believe they
did cancel the howard the duck series kevin smith
was working on but they are still doing the modok
series obviously and they're still doing the hit
monkey tv series i don't really know anything
about what's going on with that hit monkey
series but the modok episodes patton oswalt said
will probably wind up dropping early next year
the big thing you may have heard recently about
modok during the marvel phase 4 live-action movies
is that originally he was supposed to be the main
villain of ant-man 3 but then recently they just
cast someone who's going to be kang the conqueror
so it sounds like they're going more in a kang
time war direction with young avengers stuff most
of you've also been playing the marvel avengers
game modok a very big character during that
obviously it's more of an inhumans plot than it
is in x-men plot i do think it's really cool that
they're finally letting them do new x-men stuff
in new marvel projects so hopefully because this
is animation they can just do whatever they want
and the funny thing about patton oswalt playing
modok because it does sound like he was born to
play this character is that he said when they
got the initial call to come on agents of shield
as the first version of the caning character
he thought that they were calling him to play
modog he also wound up showing up during the
final season of agents of shield during their
big avengers in-game time travel storyline as a
version of the koenig's grandfather from the 1930s
i don't know what their long-term plan is for this
modok animated series if it'll make it multiple
seasons they have a great pedigree they have great
casts great writers and it seems like it's going
to be pretty solid but the whole thing going
forward now with marvel tv series is that most
of them are coming through disney plus in their
big avengers level tv shows all coming from kevin
feige they really want to get you to pay for that
disney plus so that's why all their biggest stuff
is coming through disney plus they also have that
hellstrom tv show that's premiering in a couple
weeks that's trading heavily on their ghost rider
and their darker midnight son's mythology
so we'll see what that actually ends up looking
like because that's definitely not going beyond
season one they sort of canceled it after they
finished season one so it'll be a limited series
what'll be happening really soon though is that
we'll get the mandalorian season 2 episodes
obviously i'll be doing videos for that as long
as you have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all those videos when i post them and
then after that we'll get the avengers Wandavision
episodes so there's some really big stuff coming
up later this year while you wait for everything
everyone click here for the boys season 3 teaser
trailer and click here for my brand new avengers
Wandavision trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!